you did a movie with Tom Cruise but you
you were originally auditioned for Jerry
Maguire hey you blew the order how did
you got beat up by Cuba I'm gonna tell
you what happened I'm in LA in our
audition just like oh no no no I don't
know how I got in and the guy goes he's
great
we're gonna take you to New York because
they hadn't they hadn't signed Tom
Cruise on yet right we're gonna take you
to New York and reefer Tom Cruise I'm
like what I'm like oh my god so I get to
New York and I was just come on man Tom
Cruise walked in with the with the
leather jacket and despite him he looked
like he had just walked off a Top Gun
and this is always just done and this is
after living color or yeah yeah just
after that and then I had no business
being there I felt so I never get making
them a fool of myself by saying speaking
the time of Tom said where do you live
and I said oh I got two houses I live in
LA and Vegas you know I'm saying
impressing him [ __ ] I'm late on
payments and all kinds of [ __ ] listen
[ __ ] I got two hours so I said
where do you live he said Rome and I
said Rome Street Italy and I just
remember going to a craft service and
just one that's just [ __ ] this
committed or the audition itself blowing
now I'm gonna tell you when it blew it
because I kept I kept looking at him
because I imagine imagine you from Texas
and you've done a little bit of [ __ ] but
you ain't seen no real [ __ ] stars
right so I'm just sitting up watching it
and we get the reading right and we're
reading and as I'm reading you know he
does a dramatic pause you know but
that's his thing yeah I [ __ ] think he
lost his place I'll take the scripts
that know me right here
show me the money and give you say you
he says I know I was taking apart that's
okay yeah I'm [ __ ] this up I'll
[ __ ] his own up so I
but I'm booing so bad they need to start
a laughing at me right and then at one
point you know cuz he does he does he
did his lines like cuz he would have
that law whisper thing you know in TV
we're hey man what's going on another
way yes we're TV actor hey man don't you
do that
so all my lives were loud as [ __ ] and
then he would say so I couldn't hear
where he worked
nothing hey guy how was the hey guy hey
guy you got you got to get it together
so anyway I'm blowing it and the guy I
can't remember - I can't remember -
producing then he pulls me out of the
thing he goes what the [ __ ] are you
doing you gotta [ __ ] him up he's talk
you gotta take it to him and I felt like
I was like I feel like I just thrown an
interception in the big [ __ ] Texas
you know